at 3 500 meters above sea level in the
heart of the Andes Mountains lies Cusco
once the imperial capital of the Inca
Empire and later the historic capital of
colonial Peru
it's the gateway to another world
heritage site Machu Picchu the famous
15th century Inca Citadel above the
sacred Valley usually packed with
foreign tourists
but Machu Picchu is now off limits until
further notice
protesters have partially destroyed the
only access to the lost city of the
Incas
we peruvians don't even have free access
to Machu Picchu only private business
interests benefit from our heritage
a nearly two-month-long general strike
Mass protests and blocked highways have
left to Machu Picchu and Cusco devoid of
tourists the main source of income here
this wall belongs to what was the Palace
of the sixth Inca the Inca Roca and one
of its main attractions is this it's
called the 12 angle Stone and it is an
example of an extraordinary technique
called polygono masonry and it's one of
the reasons why tourists come here to
see this except that now they are
practically aren't any
hotels are empty and losing Millions
this has been a terrible blow with the
events that we're witnessing the
occupancy in hotels until March has
dropped 90 percent because of
cancellations unemployment soared to 75
percent
some shops have closed under threats
from Strikers but Don Mariano's shop
that sells handmade shoes is still open
for business
we don't sell anything anymore we have
to pay a lot of rent the staff is on
strike and there's no tourists from
North America and Europe
we run into women who make their living
by offering tourists to take photos with
their baby alpacas they've come to Cusco
from their Village two hours away but
they say there isn't enough business to
buy food for their animals
Peru used to receive 2 million tourists
before the pandemic and the strike but
now these indigenous protesters are the
only ones who arrive here in large
numbers
we want the President to resign to leave
and for new elections to be called
that's the only way we will get back to
normal
but there's no sign that either the
president or congress will meet the
protesters demands while one of the
world's most attractive tourist
destinations sinks into despair
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Cusco Peru